i want we have not talked about jordan
peterson for a while
but he is back on the
sort of speaking trail
and um our colleague john sent me this
clip uh from jordan peterson at stanford
university a few days ago this was on i
guess it was a couple weeks ago this was
a
sort of an event on classical liberalism
at the graduate school of business at
stanford university
and um
i don't even know how to explain this
jordan peterson started weeping
because he's so upset about climate
activism not climate change he's not
upset because of climate change he's
upset because of climate activism and he
seems unstable completely unhinged
really seems to have lost it i'm going
to play a couple minutes because you've
got to see the lead-up and the lead-up
is he finds it so upsetting that
sometimes people are negative about the
outlook of the planet and humanity and
he says that the problem is that people
are being
uh
people are getting depressed because of
climate activists okay check this out
didn't even have any children it's like
no
there's no excuse for that there's zero
excuse for that i saw a professor at
an event something like this
he came out and trumpeted this bloody
environmentally friendly house he built
and you know fair enough man it was a it
was a pretty interesting house but
not everybody had the four million
dollars that that it took him to build
it and i'm not criticizing his money
even it's like
he's had some money good for him he
built a house okay but then to trumpet
that as a moral virtue well you're
pushing it there and then he came out to
all the kids and he said you know my
wife and i decided that we're only going
to have one child and i think that's one
of the most ethical things we could have
possibly done and i would strongly
encourage you to do the same i thought
you son of a [ __ ] you get up in front
of these young people a lot of these
kids were
uh children of first generation
immigrants from china and and he showed
all these images you know of these
terrible factories in china these
endless rows of sterile mechanism that
were subordinating all the chinese
people to this terrible you know
capitalist
machine and i thought
if you're still following this
it's about to get really weird i don't
understand half the audience is looking
at those factories and thinking that's a
hell of a lot better than struggling
through the mud under mao buddy
and so
he i don't know where he thought he was
but to come out in front of all those
kids and basically tell them that the
whole human enterprise is so goddamn
corrupt that the best thing they could
possibly do is limit their
multiplication and to think of himself
as a scholar and an educator it was just
i did say something by the way it was
rather uncomfortable and he stomped off
the stage
but
that's no message for young people
that's no there's no excuse for that you
think well
you know we're going to destroy the
planet we have to do this we have to
demoralize the youth to be ethical it's
like yeah really that's your theory
you're going to demoralize young people
to be ethical that's your theory it's
like you should go and think about that
for like a year
and i'm passionate about this you know
because
you have no idea how many people that's
killing
you have no idea i see people everywhere
all over the world they're so
demoralized
especially
young people especially
young people with a conscience because
they've been told since they were little
that there's nothing to them but
corruption and power it's like how the
hell do you expect them to react
so he
this is bizarre obviously
there's a real difference between young
people are told that you are made up of
corruption and and whatever
and hey we have some hard problems that
we're facing
and they need to be solved and you might
make choice i mean there's an entire
movement i think it's called the
anti-natalist which basically says like
we can't bring people we should all
everybody should stop reproducing
because
we are
rapidly heading towards lack of
sustainability and on and on and on now
i happen to disagree with that i think
the way we solve our problems is
actually
by reproducing and creating people that
are going to solve these problems that's
that's my view because i i guess i'm
more optimistic than pessimistic but
this whole thing weeping because people
learn
that
things aren't looking so good in some
senses that it would be immoral to hide
everyone from that now i'm with you you
we don't want to demoralize people no we
want to say hey the we've look at all
these problems humanity has solved and
then here are the problems now facing us
and let's solve them but i would be
crying over how we're destroying the
planet
not about how kids might find it
upsetting that we're destroying the
planet that seems very very backwards
and another one of these really weird
weepy he it just he seems emotionally
dysregulated is what that seems like and
also
sort of wrong on the facts if you can be
both at once which clearly you can